[Music]
that's hot
hey guys it's katie and i love
a food challenge so today i've asked my
friends kelly
and jasmine to join us to see who can
turn an iconic celebrity look
into an edible masterpiece they're only
gonna have three hours to complete this
task and at the end i will be joined by
as
is producer and fashion expert lindsay
webster she bakes she knows everything
about beauty and fashion
it's gonna be great i think it's time to
find out what celebrity look
we've chosen three two
one ariana grande i love her
it's ariana grande i freaking love her
i love ariana grande i think she's
beautiful
all her outfits are crazy but this looks
intimidating the dress
is beautiful but the color is quite dim
a little worried about the color of the
dress especially in terms of food
it's going to be great i promise and it
is a competition so there will be
prizes the winner will take home this
beautiful
interview trophy that we've made here at
tasty and the loser will take home
the thank you next i am so stressed
about
kelly being my competitor once she's my
friend and two she went to culinary
school and is like a chef
do you want to win yeah i want a
freaking wig let's cook
the look your time starts now
just brainstorm for a minute for kelly's
masterpiece she'll be making a seven
layer cake with gold speckled champagne
strawberry jam placed between each layer
the outside will be covered with fondant
ruffles and the top tier will be covered
with silver sparkles and a gray
satin ribbon to finish it kelly will top
the cake with sugar strands to mimic
ariana's iconic blonde ponytail
i feel like i can pull this off in three
hours the only thing that scares me is i
have to cook
and cool cakes i think i'm gonna go with
a beverage jasmine's dish will be built
in a gold rim glass
filled with gold boba sweetened earl
grey tea and charcoal infused oat milk
on top she'll place a cotton candy cloud
and strawberry roses
finally for a show-stopping entrance
jasmine will make a sugar cage to cover
the entire dish kelly's making a cake
so i'm a little scared i they don't even
compare you guys might want to get
started you only have three hours okay
yeah i think i'm good this is what i'm
going with let's see starting with some
water i'm going to add in my sugar
and then a couple tablespoons of tapioca
starch i am making my boba first because
it's gonna take
so long all right i'm gonna throw this
in the microwave one minute
15 second intervals i'm using 24 karat
gold
edible glitter to make my boba glittery
hopefully boba is going to help me win
especially incorporating 24k
gold into there the gold is because well
it's very vibrant it's ariana grande
she's glamorous and also it's an ode to
the grammys
and i'm going to start by creaming some
butter and sugar when
i'm under pressure it's like a toddler
running around naked
chaos you're trying to catch them it's
just crazy
so the butter and sugar is creamed now
i'm going to add some egg whites i'm
going to combine my dry ingredients a
flour
baking powder and salt then over here i
have some room temperature milk oil
and some vanilla and then we're going to
alternate adding our wet ingredients and
our dry ingredients
my batter is combined i chose to do a
seven layer cake to represent one of the
songs she was nominated for
seven rings what are you working on
right now just a seven layer cake no big
deal what are you working on
just some tea so my boba does not coming
together i don't think it likes the the
gold glitter
it's all crumbly and it's not supposed
to be like this
things are off to a really rocky start
i've never incorporated the glitter
into boba dough before and it is coming
out very crumbly and so i'm adjusting
the water
to match the dough texture but
everything's crumbling my cake batter
came together really quickly i got them
in the oven and i'm feeling pretty
confident just because of that little
hiccup i'm not sure if it'll boil
correctly with the the texture that i'm
looking for i'm not gonna freak out
because it'll mess up my next few steps
all right so next up i'm gonna make some
strawberry jam
to go in between the layers of cake i
read that strawberries are her favorite
dessert
and to spice it up i'm going to add a
little champagne do you have extra
glasses should we toast right now yeah
yeah cheers
the burner is not heating and i'm
getting stressed out because these
strawberries have to cook down
and soften so i put a lid on top to see
if that's going to help speed up the
process
i'm starting to get worried about the
time because it has to cool before i can
assemble the cake
i'm rolling out some of my dough i cut
them into the size
where i'm going to roll them to and then
instead of rolling them one by one i
kind of just put multiple
on my palm i'm adding some tapioca flour
to the bowl
i'm gonna toss the balls in there i just
don't want them to stick to each other
so i'm still waiting for that to come to
a boil
but in the meantime i'm gonna add some
champagne to our cornstarch to make a
slurry that's going to incorporate
easily into our jam so there's no clumps
i've never made this before i'm hoping
the champagne flavor really comes
through but
we'll see so now i'm going to add my
cornstarch slurry
to my jam the thing with cornstarch once
it's boiled it means it's activated and
it
has second what you want it to i'm going
to transfer it to a bowl
to let it cool i'm going to go pop this
in the freezer and then i'm going to
stir in those gold flakes because i
don't want them to melt the bubbles
taking really long
this is very tedious work i'm not
stressed i think we should uh when you
get a moment we should
have another little cheers i'm almost
done with actually
cheers so i just have some traditional
buttercream here
i creamed up some butter added some
powdered sugar added a little milk to
thin it out
and i'm going to tint it gray to match
the dress i couldn't find gray
so we're going with black i'm just going
to do a little at a time i feel like it
looks
like a blue tint that literally looks
like the exact same color does it
yes all right by the way you only have
like an hour and a half what's left
all right i just took my cakes out of
the oven i popped them in the freezer
hoping that's going to help cool them
down quicker i'm just waiting here can
you help me yes
not allowed cause she helped me kelly's
waiting for her case to cool i'm still
making the boba rolling each one
and kelly was so nice she came and
helped me but i want to beat her
i'm hoping it'll become more transparent
as it's boiling
thank you kelly for helping me rule the
bobas i'm finally done
i'm going to throw the boba in and let
them boil for about 20 minutes or so
this jam has cooled it's a little
thicker than i wanted so i'm just gonna
another splash
of champagne so this is an adult cake
don't serve this to your kids so i'm
just gonna sprinkle some of that edible
gold
in there i've never done this it's kind
of like dissolving into the red
it's not looking great i'm having major
regrets so what do i do
i just keep adding more thinking it's
going to fix it i'm adding a couple bags
of
earl grey tea once we add in the oat
milk it'll make it nice and creamy
i'm really waiting but it's taking so
long i thought i'd be
way ahead of kelly she's making a cake
i'm leveling these cakes
the first one was very uneven look how
good this cake looks the crumb is tight
it's super moist
now i'm gonna start assembling i got
seven layers to make so here we go
i am going to steep my tea for about
four to five minutes
now i'm going to infuse my oat milk with
some activated charcoal gonna use that
as the creamer to get that
beautiful gray ombre look to get the
color of ariana grande's dress i am
using
activated charcoal in a few of my
elements i don't use activated charcoal
very often
never actually so i'm kind of just
testing hopefully it doesn't affect the
flavor that i'm going for
i just built a wall of buttercream
around the edge of the cake
so it will hold in the jam and i'm going
to do that in between each layer
all right time for the crumb coat this
is just like a thin layer
to pick up all these crumbs so they
don't end up on your outer layer
this is sabotage in itself because kelly
knows i love watching people make cakes
and now i'm a little distracted i feel
like i don't have enough icing to make
this
but must keep going are you hot
yeah i'm hot my icing is falling off the
side
i'm not a professional here's the good
thing about crumb coat though it doesn't
matter what it looks like because
nobody's gonna see it i will have to add
this into my teeth so i don't want it to
dilute too much
i'm putting the crumb coat on my cake
and the cakes are sliding
everywhere because they're not cooled
down enough and i'm not getting those
straight sides that i wanted
my boba is done boiling i'm going to let
it sit for another 20-30 minutes
so i'm going to get started making the
brown sugar syrup bath just brown sugar
and water just gonna mix it until it
thickens
okay so my cakes are crumb coated i
popped them in the freezer to kind of
get some more stability on them and in
the meantime i'm rolling out some gray
fondant and these will be the ruffles
for the dress
i think i'm gonna have to make like at
least a hundred ruffles basically i'm
just like
flattening out the edges a little bit so
it looks a little more realistic and i'm
gonna take my circle
and just fold it into like whatever
shape you want to get a little ruffle
the boba isn't looking exactly how i
wanted it to look
i wanted it to be clear with gold
speckles but i'm kind of digging the way
they're coming out the brown sugar syrup
wasn't quite thick enough but it's fine
i'd rather have it in there
so that the bobas don't stick together
going into this three hours is more than
enough time so i thought
but i'm running super behind and i
didn't even have time to thicken my
brown sugar syrup
so i am gonna make a sugar cage this is
my
least confident and biggest hill that i
will have to overcome today
i am using this giant jar and this will
go over
my drink and i'll lift it off oh my god
jasmine so i'm adding half a cup of
water
mixing in some corn syrup and some sugar
and i'm gonna bring it to 311 degrees
i love the ruffles i'm making i was a
little cautious going into it i'd never
done it before
but i think they really look like
ruffles and they're beautiful i'm gonna
put these out of the way and go grab
those cakes this is what i wanted
finally something worked out it's super
stiff so i'm going to add this layer of
icing get it super smooth
i am just like an amateur when it comes
to icing cakes and
it's like sliding all over the place i'm
trying to create really even sides
i'm going to coat it in silver sprinkles
and it's kind of reminds me of big
diamond earrings she has on in the photo
so that'd be pretty the sprinkles on the
cake are just
not what i wanted i want them to be
thicker to hide the imperfections of the
icing and
be more glittery if it's not the right
temperature it's not going to hold its
shape and if it's not going to hold its
shape i won't have a sugar cage
and then i'll lose i am now going to rim
my glass with some
gold glitter just more gold more fancy
more extravagance and luxury i'm just
greasing with some oil spray to keep the
sugar from sticking onto the jar
all right my top layers are back in the
freezer and now i'm going to add icing
to my bottom layers and then add the
ruffles for the top of the sugar cage
i'm going to do a little butterfly
ariana grande has a
butterfly tattoo so i'm going to use
some sugar and shape it into a butterfly
okay it has reached hard crack stage i'm
gonna let this cool for just like
a little bit so it can thicken up i'm
gonna stick these little ruffles that i
made
all along the cake and line it so it
looks like a dress okay i started
building and then i realized
i need to build it on the kickstand
because once i add the ruffles i can't
move it
so
do you think i should put my arm through
it and kind of like drip it this way no
no no no why not sugar is like the worst
burn you can have
this is not going to work the sugar cage
i don't want to talk about it actually i
thought that sugar cage was going to be
easy peasy lemon squeezy this is
when you rip something off of plastic
and you see all the
glue underneath when kelly looked over
and saw my sugar cage
her reaction pretty much told me to stop
i'm gonna give you some advice
sometimes it's best if it's not working
just to move on
oh that's hot are you okay did you burn
yourself yeah
sugar is like the worst burn you can
have
all right i'm gonna try the butterfly
thing now let's just hope my artistic
skills
can pull this off i got one wing down it
looks pretty good actually not bad not
as bad as i thought it would be
you have 20 minutes are you serious half
my cake is still naked
my sugar cage failed well i thought i'd
do like a little retail
therapy guys
each get to accessorize with these
fashion statements inspired by ariana
what ariana's signature pony
katie just gave us this hair
transformation and i'm kind of into it i
don't think kelly is
i don't have time for this it's going to
weigh me down i'm going to grow up my
hair it's so fun to play with
not very food safe though i got my
butterfly kind of reminds me of the
chinese sugar arch
this butterfly is cute i've never tried
anything like it i love the way it came
out
i feel weighed down like this is heavy
my hair came off so i have to put it
back on yes while this is preheating i'm
going to make some strawberry roses
all right so all my ruffles are on my
cake now i'm going to do my last element
which
is making sugar to look like her hair so
i just got some sugar
and some water i'm just going to heat it
until it turns like a blonde caramel
color i'm just going to put on the
skewers and then they will
come out of the cotton candy so to make
the cotton candy black
i am using black sanding sugar i process
this down to be extra fine
it's nesting wow the color is a little
lighter than i
had anticipated it's too fluffy no it's
fine
all right this is the perfect color i'm
gonna let it cool a little bit and then
i'm gonna twirl it around this ring
the sugar hair is gonna be the most
challenging part i'm not an expert on
working with sugar this is actually a
little lighter than i want it to be so
i'm gonna mix some of the sanding sugar
with a little bit of activated charcoal
see if i can get the base to be darker
and i can build on that
okay and by the way this is your guys's
10 minute warning
okay no i'm going to take a little bit
of this satin ribbon
and put it around the base of the cake
to replicate her gloves so now i'm going
to find the front of my cake and then
add the top layer
on the final stages not wispy enough
almost my sugar has melted down the
color is perfect but the consistency i'm
having a little bit of trouble with it
can't be too thick it can't be too thin
and if it gets too cool quickly then it
all breaks apart how much time is left
five minutes
what no okay gotta try again
i'm really struggling with this sugar
hair i feel like it's gonna be the
element that
brings my whole dish together and if i
don't get it right i'm gonna be really
bummed i'm not sure if the activated
charcoal was a mistake or not the cotton
candy
will not take the color of the activated
charcoal and it's driving me insane wow
does it look like hair my sugar's still
not melted jesse you have three minutes
i'm already running low on time the
activated charcoal is not cooperating
with the cotton candy machine and kelly
is pretty much done with her cake
just started working we're on a super
super time crunch
it started working i'm very happy it's
nice and poofy
and finally it's getting that fluff the
poopiness the cloud that i
envisioned it's time to assemble and uh
it's go time kelly are you done
i'm done here let me hold it oh thank
you start with some gold boba
who literally have one minute ah
i whipped some cream together all right
you have 10 seconds
i think kelly's is gonna taste good i
know it looks good
i looked over at jasmine and the moment
she placed that sugar butterfly on the
cotton candy i was like i'm done
your time is up your eyes time is up
i'm very happy with how the boba came
out super shiny
and super shimmery and the flavor of the
tea
chef's kiss i love the way my cake
turned out not to toot my own horn but i
had this vision in my head and it came
out perfectly and i'm just so happy all
right should we go grab crazy lindsay
and see what they think oh i'm nervous
but yeah let's do it
oh my goodness i think this is kind of
that drink where there's like cotton
candy on top
it's a little avant-garde it's not exact
replica of the dress
but the dress itself is avant-garde so i
feel like there's inspiration here
is this glitter boba i don't think my
dish
looks exactly like the picture of ariana
grande and her dress
but i do really think that it captures
the spirit of the dress
this reminds me almost of you know like
super sweet 16
this looks like that i can see the
resemblance here
straight across from the dress this gold
sugar ring looks reminiscent of
her golden hair and oh my god the
ruffles
look just like the ruffles in the dress
all right so i think one thing that's a
little bit of a miss for me on these is
that
this one is a little too on the nose
whereas this one
is very far away from the nose i'm gonna
dig in
and see how these bad boys taste it
looks like strawberry in here
strawberries and cream which is my
favorite kind of cake
this is really spongy that champagne
strawberry filling is delicious it's
just heavenly the only problem for me
is i'm not a big fan of fondant let's
try
the boba i love boba so i have
expectations
whoa that tastes rich that earl grey
pairs really nice of the brown sugar
and the consistency of boba's important
this is very good
katie and i are going to discuss and
we're going to reveal the winner
i'm nervous about lindsay coming in i
know she's a fashion expert but i think
she's going to be impressed with the
ruffles on my
cake that look just like the dress i
don't know what she's thinking i have no
idea what she's thinking i don't know if
she likes boba
why am i nervous well look at all of our
ponytails first of all
just three girls in their ponies i truly
feel like i'm standing
in the presence of greatness you both
did so
good this was a really hard decision for
katie and me to make we're waiting for
the results
and it is so nerve-wracking i just want
to know who won
so the winner of the ariana grande
challenge is
the bobo this dress is so avant-garde
and creative and different and we felt
like the dessert and
captured the ariana grande spirit from
the inside to the outside
i won i really did not see this coming
yours was seriously perfect oh thank you
i didn't win but honestly i think this
one might be the cuter trophy
i almost feel like kelly should come in
and i should hand this over to her i'm
really excited that jasmine won
she was a champion all day long thank
you guys so much for watching let us
know what other celebrity looks you want
us to try next thank you next
round two i'm coming for you jasmine
let's go did you do this competition
again
no i'm not gonna do this again with
kelly i'm gonna lose i'm gonna take
beginners luck and peace out i'm done
as well